good afternoon everyone
yes my talk is called let's webdev like
it's 1999 quick show of hands actually
who was developing back in 99 or early
2000s okay that's good that's a good
number of people maybe 30 40 % or so so
I'm gonna be sharing a little bit of but
my story is how I got into web
development and kind of take a walk down
memory lane for those of you who were
around those at that time or for those
of you who weren't you know this will be
a history lesson for you so see what it
was like to develop back then and
hopefully learn some things along the
way and also appreciate you know the
things that we have now even though we
like to complain about them so I tweeted
out a link to these slides if you're
interested so on my Twitter account been
MVP you want to follow along or just
know that you have them they're there
for you and it's kind of clipped at the
bottom of the screen but there's also a
bitly link that you can follow as well
so but to get started can I get everyone
to stand up I have everyone to stand up
so we just all ate lunch right and it's
starting to settle in there right and
I'm afraid that you will all fall asleep
during this talk so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna do in squats like this
okay all right and if you're not
physically able to do it or don't want
to don't feel like you have to you can
just move your arms as you want to but
we're gonna do it all in unison to get
that blood flowing yeah so we can feel
energized through it okay so we'll start
at zero since you know JavaScript of
course and we'll count off our ways up
okay ready let's do it zero yeah one two
three four doing great five six yep you
look as silly as your
eight and nine and that's it yeah all
right awesome job everyone but before
you sit down I want you to fist bump
your neighbor and say hello to them
just say hello awesome awesome okay now
we're ready to go
so to formally introduce myself like I
said my name is Benna leg Badu I'm a
Christian a husband and a father this is
a picture of my family here at my
sister-in-law Naima is her wedding so I
guess you can guess who she is Naima is
the one in the wedding dress obviously
on the far left is my wife rashida we've
been married almost eight years Oh be
eight years in September and she's
holding our youngest daughter Avery
she'll be two in September as well and
then I'm with my older daughter Simone
and she's four and a half years old I am
a principal front-end engineer at
Eventbrite and I'm on our platform team
and we focus on front-end infrastructure
as well as our design system so I do a
lot of that type of work but I'm not
here to talk about what I do now I'm
here to talk about me 20 years ago and
it all began with this so I in the
summer of 1998 when all my friends were
out having fun I was in this summer
program and in the summer program they
taught basic programming language and it
so happened that basic was also on the
ti calculators so I started programming
games I made like bowling and things
like that and I made programs math
programs math apps as well and in fact I
actually I used to make like apps like
slope calculator and things for algebra
in order to check my my answers for
homework or check my answers for tests
so I figured like if I knew how to
program it that means I knew the answers
right I knew what I was doing
so it wasn't cheating I mean it really
was cheating right totally was cheating
but you know that's how I I told myself
was okay so originally when I had the
calculator there wasn't this when I was
making the games there wasn't a plug to
connect my computer to my calculator so
I used to actually program the apps on
the calculator like by hand
you know programming this way and I used
to type it up on the computer printout
the app and then on the way to school
sitting in the backseat of my mom's car
I would just transcode what I had my
paper to the calculator and make apps
like that when I look back on myself
I'm so embarrassed but you know hey I
got me here so it's good
exactly so I started making apps and
people would ask like oh how do I do it
how do I learn to make programs on the
TI calculator so first what I started
doing is I would make tutorials and I
used this like the help system and
windows so I've been using a Mac for
like over three years so I don't
remember how I don't know how Windows
works now but back then there's actually
apps that would pop up when you collect
f1 and help and it was like this whole
app and you could have articles in there
and they would cross link each other and
you can search so I built that and had
that for tutorials but it wasn't a great
way to distribute things people would
have to download it and such so I
realized that actually the web is
probably the best way to distribute this
type of content so I created my first
website on Geo cities yeah
it's beautiful I know so great look at
that thank you very much I use geo
cities angelfire was also popular back
then it was between geo cities and Angel
Fire and I was actually able to go into
the wayback machine to 2000 and actually
find this website up so and take the
screenshot of it so this is early 2000s
basically now so this is probably like
middle of high school or so for me when
I was when I built the website and it
was a full-on application Geocities
handled the backend and I just did what
was the front end then which was
basically HTML and some JavaScript
sprinkled around and I would FTP or File
Transfer Protocol files up to their
servers and that's how you get into
production you just uploaded it right
there so I wanted to walk through it I
definitely made this logo in Microsoft
Paint and the clipart was actually from
PowerPoint and you can see I tried to
put the question mark on the book but
obviously the I didn't rotate it
correctly the the perspective is all
wrong and all off and I used Comic Sans
of course for the lettering and two
different colors of Comic Sans great
looks beautiful and of course I had to
have the the trusty dusty count counter
on the page so the counter doesn't work
anymore for whatever reason but everyone
has to count how many people had visited
the sites back then and on the far right
I also had for some reason decided it
was a good idea to display today's date
and like one of the most prominent
places on the page but the coolest thing
no the coolest thing is that it still
works like the JavaScript still works I
did a document dot write line and I just
wrote it right in and like this is the
primary reason that JavaScript is
backwards compatible so my website can
work twenty years later right it's still
there it still displays the date I may
by it and this text here this you know
slew of text in the pinna page here I
don't know if you can read it but I
suggest I recommend that anybody viewing
this page view it in America Online AOL
that's the best browser to view it in
and you know maybe it'll look okay and
Internet Explorer and Netscape Navigator
maybe and I also suggest that if you
viewing this and an 800 by 600
resolution monitor and make sure that
you make your window big enough so that
is 800 and 600 so it's crazy those days
but you can see it's still responsive
like the windows the screen is actually
much wider and the table layout was able
to grow to it so I'm impressed with
myself I was gonna say that okay what I
was able to do as a high schooler back
then and then here on the far right I
have this poll asking what is your
internet connection speed and one of the
options is 14 by for KBS VPS so
basically the speed of our conference
Wi-Fi right now and then lastly at the
bottom I have this navigation this
navigation here so it's fixed at the
bottom the rest of the page Scrolls and
then that's how you can click around and
when you click the page would would
change above so this is something that's
like way above its time looks like it's
flexbox or grid but we did it a
different way and I'll explain a little
bit more about that but just for fun
let's take a look at what Yahoo looked
like at the exact same time this was
Yahoo back in the day this was also
amazon.com would it look like back in
the day at the same time so I think my
site looked better than both of those be
honest
it's okay so let's fast forward two
decades to present time I have a blog
been MVP calm that I built in Gatsby
it's a react static site generator and
it uses like all the latest technologies
in order to be to be performant and to
be fast and optimized and things like
that so static site generation didn't
exist back then you know basically I was
my own static site generator cuz I had
to make every single one of the pages
but now I can use react and using graph
QL and other technologies CSS and jas
material UI web pack babel all these
things i can leverage in order to make
sophisticated user interfaces you know
just to build a blog and i was talking
to my friend who just recently graduated
from UC Berkeley boot camp coding boot
camp that they have and this I was
reading the syllabus for what they were
going to be learning over the 12 weeks
and that they're learning all these
things html5 css3 they would be using
express and react and my sequel and
getting all these different things they
were learning just you know to have the
minimum amount of skills to be able to
get an entry-level position it's kind of
crazy you know where the bar is now for
what's a minimal minimally valuable
viable the skills that you need in order
to build a website now so you know we
come to meetups we come to conferences
like this to hear from people to learn
about what we should do what we need to
do in order to build great websites you
know we have to learn about
accessibility or we have to learn about
service workers and all these different
things in order to make a compelling
website I don't actually don't think
that a modern-day website now can be
built by a single person right you need
multiple people who have experienced in
different areas in order to to build a
great website now or you have to rely on
a lot of open source technology that has
already done it so far
so the bar I wasn't always so high you
know it was really really low like
really low like really low I don't even
think there was a bar back then in order
to build websites so I wanted to take a
look at some of the aspects of what it
took what we did back then when we were
building some websites so before css3
came along and we had a flex box and we
had grid we needed a way to layout our
pages right and many times we would have
navigation that we wanted fixed
somewhere and then we wanted the content
to change and the navigation to stay
fixed there so maybe you would have a
global header at the top or you would
have a navigation that would be on the
left or in my case I thought it was a
good idea to have the navigation at the
bottom for some reason so you have the
navigation at the bottom and have the UI
laid out that way so you may be thinking
I'm talking about table layouts because
that was a way to do table layouts
hopefully none of you are doing table
layouts now but I'm not gonna ask you to
raise your hand so you don't put
yourself on the spot but I'm talking
about something that predated tables for
layouts I'm talking about using frame
sets yeah frame set to frame sets are
even deprecated now so some people don't
may not even know what a frame set is
but before I even get into how frame
sets works I want to just take us on a
take in this HTML right we're using all
caps for HTML we decided screaming case
was a good idea to write our HTML right
and if you look at some of the
properties look at margin height or
frame border like we don't have quotes
around our values like you just put the
value there and the frame tag it's not
self closing there's no close to it we
just went on to the next tag and somehow
the browser was able to figure it out
you know it's fun times back then uh-huh
so what this code is actually doing
here's a visual of it so we have a frame
at the top and then beneath it we have
three frames that are aligned in a
column
so the frame of the top is fixed the
left frame number of frame number 2 is
fixed on the left and then frame number
4 is fixed and then the content and
between flexes to whatever amount is
left in the window so going back to it
to the code each frame pointed to
another HTML file that was loaded in
inside of it so in this case there would
be a header h2 ml that would just have
the content for the header and then
there was frame sets were allowed you to
organize different frames together and
they could be organized and rows
vertically or columns from left to right
and these frame sets could also be
nested so you could have nested frames
and fix the top and then have kind of
more complicated layouts there and
notice the the asterisk there inside of
the calls there so that's saying that I
want 20% on the left I want 20% on the
right and then the asterisks meant that
it flowed in between ok and we had all
this kind of like visual styling
everywhere so here I'm turning off the
frame border for instance because frames
by default had frames my people had
borders around them and if he left the
borders on they were resizable so a user
could come in and just completely jack
up your website by just dragging stuff
all over the place
so you have to turn off frames with this
no well resize attribute and then lastly
you could add this attribute called name
to your frame so what was what name was
used for was for the actual content of
those frames so here is the NAB each tml
the one that's sitting on the left hand
side so in addition to having the grid
Lite layout right we also wanted to have
those fixed panes so that you didn't
have to reload the whole page the nav
isn't changing the header isn't changing
the ads on the right aren't changing so
inside of nav that HTML the links like
for instance the about link for instance
would go to the about page but we
obviously don't want it to load inside
the nav we want it to load in the middle
so that's what the target attribute
would do the target would actually point
to a different window or a different
frame like now but nowadays we only use
target for blank write underscore blank
to open up a new window but actually
that was the original purpose of target
was to target different frames and
target different windows and for some
reason in this code didn't have to
actually close the Li like the browser
knew how to continue going with Li so it
was pretty pretty cool type of code that
we used to write I guess it was I guess
it was cool it was cool to look back on
I guess as a history lesson so like I
said html5 deprecated frame set so he
actually can't use these anymore
they still work but they're deprecated
so if you looked at this code and if
you're familiar with CSS like modern CSS
you may be thinking that's just like how
CSS grid works and this is basically the
code rewritten in modern HTML and modern
CSS using CSS grid so there's all the
CSS on the right that helps align things
and fix things but it actually lays it
out the exact same way the only
difference in the benefit with this is
that the main tag which is used for the
main content is now actually above the
navigation the left navigation and
because of CSS grid allows us to reorder
things visually even though the content
and the mark-up is one way is great for
SEO because the content in the main is
is more important but CSS grid is way
too modern for us ok so let's go back
two decades again and talk about another
thing that we had challenges with in the
early 2000s 1999
so here is the nej s calendar that I
took and laid out this way and all we
want to do is take the descriptions and
indent them forty pixels inside from the
header like that's the objective of what
we're trying to do
so naturally we know CSS most of us know
CSS probably and we would use a selector
and margin left to just indent it forty
pixels and then and bam we're done right
simple enough or maybe you will over
engineer it and use bootstrap grid and
all that stuff to solve it but in the
end and the end we're using CSS right
but what happens if CSS doesn't exist
yet or there's a time where it did exist
but you couldn't rely on every browser
to support CSS like what do you do then
like what's the solve that you're gonna
have and I hear people like whispering
it I hear you whispering it yeah not
tables no we would use a one by one gift
called the spacer get yeah who remembers
the spacer gift yes yes that was that
was pretty impressive technology this
this spacer good and yeah I'm calling a
gift not Jeff it's I say yes okay so
anyway it was one by one gift or its
spacer gif or transparent that gift and
it was this just one pixel by one pixel
transparent gift so you could just see
completely through it but you could size
it to whatever size you want it so if
you want to invent something 40 pixels
you add a spacer gift right there in the
markup and you just set the width of it
to 40 pixels and bam it's indented 40
pixels or if you want something 40
pixels down you would set the height of
it to 40 pixels and if you want it to go
left and right then you would do both
width and height of the image and you
just you know throw these spacer gifts
all over your HTML in order to get our
pixel perfect layouts that we wanted
right so it's all it's like all of this
styling was in the markup in order to
accomplish this and I definitely use it
all over the place and you may be
thinking we
you can also solve this thing with non
breaking space entities yeah use that
all the time as well just throw those in
there
I still use those today to be honest but
those are dependent on the font size
right so you couldn't exactly guarantee
that you're gonna get 40 pixels with it
but it was still another way to just get
that spacing that you want which was
great so after that CSS became like a
legitimate thing right so we had HTML
and CSS that we could use as our
disposal super awesome so no longer now
that we had CSS we no longer had to
style you know put colors in the body
tag like style our text and our link and
our background right there in the body
tag didn't have to do that anymore no
longer did we have to use the font tag
in order to style our text so in order
to set the font face or the color or the
size right there in the font tag the
font tag is so old that it's now like
obsolete it's like past and deprecated
is like just doesn't exist we're trying
to pretend like it never ever happened
apparently okay so I used to use the
font tag all over the place in my code
in order to style different things and
if you ever used like WYSIWYG editors
back in the day and looked at the HTML
that they generated there are font tags
like all over the place as well so still
at that at this time you know early 2000
so we're still using tables for layout
and apparently there's some people here
who still do but you know I won't call
you out but we no longer now that we had
CSS we no longer had to style the table
using all the attributes so didn't if I
set the width or the border color or the
border thickness or cell padding like
all those attributes that we had in
there however well we ended up using CSS
the most for was not pulling out the
styling from the markup we actually used
CSS the most
for screwing with link colors okay it's
like hey you know what I can make the
default link red I could turn take off
the underline I could make it bold I
could make it so that no one knows what
is a link and what's not a link it's
like amazing what you can do and back
then the default a link that would you
had visited was always purple for some
reason by default so we always
automatically change that to be the same
as a regular link here so this code the
regular link is red and not underlined
oh but when you hover over it oh all of
a sudden the underlined shows up that's
amazing it's interactive like look how
cool this is
it was it was it was so much fun and I
decided to make the hover black instead
of a blue link so we were able to create
all this dynamic dynamic interfaces just
by using the hover pseudo-class and it
only really applied to a tags at that
time so CSS when it was first created
was originally there really just to pull
out our styling from the markup we
didn't have anything fancy we didn't
have CSS transforms we didn't have
border-radius so we didn't have to like
cut Photoshop images in order to get
rounded corners on things we didn't have
transitions for animations like we had
none of those that back then it was just
to get the styling out of the markup so
dealing with links and messing with
links is all we could really do at that
time so one more thing so you know how
there's a lot of back-end engineers now
are always saying how Java Script is a
toy language or a play language and we
always get mad and say no it's not you
know we have es6 we have async functions
like it's amazing what you can do when
javascript people are building highly
concurrent low latency servers we've got
super sophisticated web applications
that use service workers like it's
amazing what javascript can do we have a
whole conference just around the
language
but two decades ago JavaScript really
was a toy language okay and we did
really really silly things with it like
whenever anybody visits my website I'm
gonna say welcome to my website and oh
it's not just the first time they come
to the website it's every time they come
to my website right and we would do
silly things like put script tags in the
head which we know now slow down the
rendering and of course I had my
document dot write line like right in
the body to render out the date for some
reason like unobtrusive javascript
wasn't a thing back then okay
so instead of having onload and calling
this global say hello function like I
really should have a JavaScript file
that's gonna have an add event listener
handler on it and do it that way attach
it to the body but we didn't have jQuery
yet jQuery came like the mid 2000s late
2000s so writing JavaScript for all the
browser's was actually pretty difficult
at that time so we could only do the
simplest things like even just to add an
event handler ie
had attach event and the standards was
add event handler so he has to deal with
those two differences it was just a
nightmare
and debugging and ie was a nightmare -
like are in the browsers in general all
we had was alert debugging okay so the
only way you could know what was going
on your APIs have an alert and try to
see what the values of things were and
why you were in certain places look we
didn't even have console that log
because there was no console yet even
though console that log or console
debugging now was considered like subpar
that would be like a hundred times
better than what we had to do then and
don't have like an alert accidentally in
a for loop or endless loop and have to
keep having alert and alert
after alert all you could do was just
basically like force quit the app
because we didn't have that special
checkbox that Chrome has now or if you
do it again and again it says hey do you
really want to have this alert again we
didn't have that you just kept having
the alerts over and over and over and
over again and ie was like a special
special specimen when it came to two
errors so your users if there was an
error on your page your users will get
this popup on the page for every single
error and it's like this cryptic message
that you should like I'm trying to
imagine like my mom trying to understand
what's going on with this or your
grandparents are like it was crazy do I
click yes so I click no what does that
mean and things like that uh I was just
development back then was was just
special
but then came along like in the mid
2000s something called Firebug so you
may not have heard a Firebug but you
should be very thankful for Firebug
because Firebug completely changed the
game in terms of web development it was
this initially it was an extension to
Firefox that allowed you to actually see
what was going on on the in your CSS to
have a console to be able to debug your
JavaScript it's what got me off of ie
onto Firefox and then originally then
after that I went to Chrome and never
went back but you know it was truly
revolutionary I don't think the whole
the whole web 2.0 with Ajax I don't
think any of that happens without
Firebug allowing us to debug our
applications so and in those days now
and now we have all this dev tooling you
know to make our lives easier to make
sure we don't ship broken code but in
the past all we had was our source code
and then we have to feed it to this
server and hope nothing broke and if you
had you know one dangling comma your
whole entire site would be broken
by it but now our code goes through so
many steps in order before it gets to
production so you know first we have
Visual Studio code vs code which I hope
all of you are using but you know that's
my plug for it which is an amazing
editor to write your code and it caches
has intellisense and has unused code
warnings and has all these extensions
and then you have typescript to make
sure that your code is solid you have
npm which allows you to import all of
these packages so you don't have to
write all these things yourselves you
have es lint for linting and jest for
writing tests so your code is robust but
don't write too many tests and only
integration right Michael that's what
that's what you said and we have
prettier so there's less fights about
ultra code should look like and of
course there's get and github which are
table stakes so that you can work
together with someone else like imagine
two people working on a site without get
like without version control like it
existed back then but only the big
companies so you would just be like
stopping on each other working on it and
we have Travis for continuous
integration which could be kicked off by
git commits and can even run tests or
deploy automatically and gulp for
running build scripts so that your code
is optimized and so that you can strip
out comments and and all these kind of
things net Allah fie for deploying it's
a great time now than what we had back
then so I wanted to say one more thing
before our finish because running out of
time or have run out of time but a quick
show of hands how many people have been
in the industry less than two years
anybody less than two years okay so we
have a few people in here so it's great
that you're here right it's great that
you want to learn because early on these
types of conferences didn't exist and
what I found is that most newbies suffer
for something called impostor syndrome
where they don't feel like they belong
here and sometimes coming to a
conference can make that worse like
there's more things that you have to
learn about
I feel even more behind right especially
if you've gone through a bootcamp like a
three-month or six-month accelerated
bootcamp and don't know feel like you
know everything furthermore there's all
of these thought leaders that say hey
you have to learn all of these old
things the old way the way I learned it
first before you can now use all the the
nice stuff and my suggestion to you all
I want to encourage you and say hey
don't stress about it you know you're
not so par you're not less than everyone
has different ways that they learn and
the most important thing is to be able
to enjoy what you're doing and build
apps and be successful that way not
going through some kind of process that
somebody else dictates to you so even if
you just graduated yesterday you can
still be an integral part of this
community you can still do great things
in this community I know people who have
been around only a year they're doing
amazing things some people I've mentored
some people I've just run into and
didn't even know they went to boot camps
until they told me like you can
definitely do awesome things don't let
anybody tell you otherwise
okay just sum it up you got this all
right and so the closeout I just wanted
to hope you enjoyed our trip on the
wayback machine if you want to ask me
any questions or reach out to me you can
hit find my Twitter bin MVP or go to my
website been MVP com or you can email me
as well I wanted to thank the conference
organizers for bringing me here and
allowing me to share it with all of you
and I don't know how many of you know
how much effort and work it takes to put
on a conference but it takes a lot of
effort from what I've seen being a
speaker so I wanted to take some time to
thank Nick and the rest of the
organizers for putting on this pumpkin
been really really great thank you so
much
and then lastly wanted to thank all of
you for listening in I know it's a
single track so you had no other choice
really to listen to me but I still
really really appreciate it thank you
very much
[Applause]